into the first question today from i go
10. are the patriots done this off
season or does bill belichick have one
more move up his sleeve
jimmy g perhaps sharing what's your
instinct tell you are they done or do
they have more moves
i think if they could get jimmy g that
would be the one move that bill
belichick would love to do right and i
think he would like to have jimmy g
as his quarterback but at this point it
doesn't look like the 49ers are ready to
move
jimmy g maybe at some point this
offseason they will perhaps
after the draft maybe not i mean we know
what john lynch has said
as you pointed out gm's lie or at least
tell the truth as they see it at the
time
but we'll see what jimmy d's future is
but that would see that mike is probably
the one move they would have left in
them that would open some eyes
if if they're able to to make that move
i
i think that that they may be waiting
for marcus mariota to be cut
by the las vegas raiders they won't
trade for them they're not going to take
on a 10 million
salary and if jimmy or if marcus mariota
excuse me is going to take less money
jimmy g may have to too
but if mariota's going to take less
money may as well just get cut
and go pick his next team without anyone
having to give up
assets to get him but mariota and cam
newton would be an intriguing
combination
in new england garoppolo i just don't
know what the 49ers are going to do
i still think sam darnold is in play
there
that's not something that potentially
would happen until after the draft
but we saw there was interest in
mitchell trubisky he ends up going to
buffalo on a one-year two and a half
million dollar deal so there must not
have been much
interest in trubisky in san francisco
and no interest in him as a potential
starter
i just think that if the 49ers get the
guy that they want dollar for dollar
upgrade over garoppolo that's when
garoppolo will be out and i still think
they'll cut him
because no one's going to trade for 25
million a year salary and beyond
quarterback
i don't rule out some sort of a move and
additional moves by the patriots
this is when i thought they would start
making their moves there are still some
big name players out there
that they could go out and try to
attract recognizable names talented guys
that as they are on the market longer
and longer shireen
those guys are going to have reduced
expectations and bill belichick be able
to get be able to get them
for a lot cheaper than he ever would
have dreamed
yeah i mean who wouldn't want to go play
at new england with what they've done
this offseason thinking
that bill belichick can get it done
again right i mean
i know some players are hesitant to go
play for bill belichick but heck you
look at his record
why wouldn't you go there you think he
has a chance to turn it around and
be a super bowl champion again so
absolutely they could make some more
moves as some of these guys salary
demands come down
they would never take back antonio brown
but hey leonard fournette
wouldn't that be something if the
patriots pluck him away from the
buccaneers and
you know he's not going to be an every
down back and that's not what the
patriots do but at a reasonable salary
he could be part of the rotation up
there and that would make for plenty of
intrigue this season
one more real quick i i sid so
epic i think is the twitter handle not
entirely sure bears fans and the rest of
the nfl are currently clowning
the team for signing andy dalton if you
were the gm shireen what move would you
have made at quarterback
well they didn't make it it couldn't get
russell wilson we know that
and that's the move you would hope if
you're the bears you're able to make but
they weren't able to move that had to
get the bridge quarterback
personally i would have resigned
mitchell trubisky i think he's a better
quarterback right now than andy dalton
is but obviously they didn't want him
back you're not going to sell him to
bears fans so they got andy dalton he'll
be their one year quarterback
i i don't think they tried hard enough
to get russell wilson and i don't know
who
leaked last week to dan patrick the
three first round picks
third round pick and two starters that's
not gonna get russell wilson you you
really gotta back up the truck of picks
and players
khalil mack etc if you want to get
russell wilson
and if you get russell wilson and he
wants to be there and he understands
it's gonna take some time to rebuild
then you got him for 10 years and he's
going to be happy and you run the
offense through him and i think that's
what i would have done
if it was up to me and bears fans
everywhere should be happy that i'm not
running the show
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports